oh
[Music]
[Music]
um I really really really
had hoped that I would not have to
specifically dedicate any of my time on
this channel to thinking about JK
Rowling again much less talking about
her I really really thought maybe I
wouldn't have to not that she was
suddenly got to stop doing what she's
been doing but I did genuinely think you
know what she's just gonna keep doing
what she's been doing I've said my piece
about what she's doing I don't think I
have much more to add
but then then
now something I want to be really clear
about before we get into this what I'm
not here to do is give a complete
history of the issues with JK Rowling
and I am definitely not here to
re-litigate the issue of whether or not
she is transphobic she is but actually
even if you think that it's debatable
whether or not she's transphobic I think
there are reasons to still be concerned
about her actions and what she has been
doing and how she has been going about
uh expressing herself of late as well as
some of the things that she has chosen
to express I think these are troubling
even if you don't believe and agree with
me that she is transphobic
so
the reason I need to talk about Miz
rolling
again
is because of a pattern of what I can
only call escalation not necessarily an
escalation of her actual beliefs because
as as she has been stating them they
have gotten maybe a little bit harsher
her core beliefs specifically in regards
to trans women but uh you know also it's
just kind of been in line with what
she's been up to but
some of how she is choosing to express
and approach how she goes about talking
about those things that has shifted that
has escalated that has become something
that needs discussing now we're going to
be going over a couple of things here
we're going to start with the whole
stuff that went on uh with Graham Norton
that's where we're gonna start because I
feel like that's the one people have the
best uh awareness of right now so we'll
start there but then I'm also going to
talk about the op-ed she wrote for the
times I am going to address a very
specific tweet that she made about
royalties that I really need to put a
some emphasis on but these are things
some of which I've said before but
clearly require reiteration some of
which are a bit new so
um I said we'd start with The Graham
Norton thing so let's go with background
on that so Graham Norton is uh an Irish
actor and uh and he's kind of a talk
show host in the UK in an on stage
interview basically got asked about well
cancel culture as a thing now his
initial response to that he did call
someone else but it was John Cleese
someone who has very recently decided to
go off about cancel culture and Norton
calls him out I think rightfully saying
in what world are you canceled I'm
reading your article in the newspaper or
you're doing interviews about how
terrible it is to be canceled the words
should be accountability now after he
said that the interviewer who I don't
know anything about so I don't know if
this was her trying to get him to
broaden his statement or if he or if she
was actually trying to goad him into
saying something like I know nothing
about this uh interviewer so I don't
want to presume but it she kind of
wanted to get more out of him than what
he said and the way she decided to do
that was by asking well that's a very
easy target isn't it as such as you know
middle-aged man is used to saying what
he wants but for example JK Rowling then
so that was how JK Rowling came into the
conversation it's really important to
note that when Norton answered that
he never addressed JK Rowling by name
and not only that he never actually made
any statement or stance about trans
issues whatsoever
either
um either siding with transactivists or
against them he literally dodged it
completely and instead decided to shift
focus with his answer and he focused on
the idea of he shouldn't be getting
asked this at all all I'm painfully
aware of is that my voice adds nothing
to that discussion and there's a couple
of reasons why he felt that way one was
it's really got nothing to do with him
and yet if he isn't really careful about
what he says there's going to be big
headlines with his name in it Graham
Norton slams Graham Norton defends
Graham Norton weighs in on and actually
Graham Norton shouldn't be in your
headline for something that he didn't
try to voice an opinion on he got
dragged into by questions like this and
he then basically kind of goes on to
condemn the general idea of interviewing
celebrities at all to ask about this
when there are actual literal experts
now he does bring up trans issues
specifically which you could argue was
an illusion to JK Rowling but again he
doesn't take a stance on them what he
said talk to trans people talk to the
parents of trans kids talk to doctors
talk to psychiatrists talk to someone
who can illuminate this in some way the
only people he names is the Kardashians
but that's not in reference to the trans
thing just as a general like why are we
asking celebrities talk to The Experts
if you want to talk about something talk
about the thing it doesn't you know you
don't need to attach a Kardashian or uh
whatever to a serious subject so that
was what he said and again broadly
speaking yeah I agree why are we seeking
out the opinions of celebrities now like
celebrities have a right to their
opinion like everybody else and if they
want to volunteer it sure but when you
pin somebody down to try and get their
opinion on this one it's something that
has nothing to do with them it's a
little odd and it's not like that's a
new thing it's not like that's unique to
issues of trans rights that's been an
issue with celebrity culture for well
for as long as we've had celebrity
culture actually now after that happened
that that sort of segment his answer to
the to those questions was put on
Twitter and then that kind of got signal
boosted by a singer-songwriter named
Billy Bragg who I'm not familiar with
and don't know a lot about now Billy
Bragg uh a little bit like the
interviewer probably did a misstep in
pulling JK Rowling into this because
again while Norton very consciously I
imagine avoided talking about her
specifically Billy Bragg did kind of in
his uh quote tweet of this imply that he
did talk about her and again at best he
talked about her obliquely in as far as
she fits the overall context of his
reply which is that she's a celebrity
who's not an expert who people are
turning to her for her opinion on
something that why so like she fits at
that but like he never specifically
named her but Billy Bragg did name JK
Rowling in his quote tweet which if you
didn't watch the full video from Grand
Norton you would then automatically
assume that he called her out by name
which again he didn't but regardless at
that point JK Rowling goes on the attack
against well against Billy Bragg
directly and Norton by implication so JK
Rowling then quote tweets Billy Bragg
and makes her sort of initial statements
about this I am going to just read these
myself I didn't get somebody to come in
and guess voice and I'm not going to try
and do an accent or do anything mocking
because I want us to address her words
plainly and I don't think mockery is
appropriate in the circumstances as much
as I disagree with what she's doing we
need to talk about this flatly and
seriously right now and in her quote
tweet she said very much enjoying the
recent Spate of bearded men stepping
confidently onto their soapboxes to
Define what a woman is firstly we'll
pause there they did no such thing again
Norton very specifically sidestepped not
only JK Rowling herself but answering
any issues on transgender questions or
political stances or his feelings about
any of that so she's basically accused
and then you know when bragging is his
retweet while he did call A JK Rowling
he also did not actually step in with
any specific opinion on the trans issues
now I don't know if he has stated
publicly his support or his position on
that previously but certainly in this
tweet he doesn't and Norton super did
not so we already have an issue of he
Norton literally went out of his way to
not say anything about quote unquote
what a woman is but rolling immediately
goes on the attack calling them both out
for something that they simply factually
at least and the specific things that
she was quote tweeting did not do
continuing on and throw their support
behind rape and death threats to those
who dare disagree okay okay this
this this is really kind of the
the heart of why this should be
disturbing and troubling even if you
aren't fully on board with the idea that
she is transphobic because she has taken
a criticism not actually of her well at
least not from Norton Brad pulled her in
but definitely when talking about Norton
a answer and a statement that was in no
way about her
as being an outright support of abuse
and threats that have been issued to her
which quick pause on that no matter what
you think of JK Rowling and I have
basically no respect left for the woman
she should not be getting death threats
rape threats or any kind of threats
nobody should be getting that I don't
care who they are that is not what
should happen to people it happens on a
very regular basis it happens to an
awful lot to trans people but that's
really just not
something that's cool so before it gets
twisted that I'm in support of that I no
no I'm not but my point in calling her
out on this is that she's basically
saying that even implying that you
disagree with her stances automatically
means that you support the worst
possible aspects of those who disagree
with her this is a very harsh version of
if you're not with me you're against me
because again Norton didn't call her out
specifically and even brag while he did
bring her into the conversation he was
linking her to the statements Norton
made which again were not specifically
about trans people and definitely did
not address online harassment in any way
shape or form but suddenly because there
was simply the implication that maybe
she's not the Voice who should be heard
on these topics her immediate response
to that is you support death threats
against me which is such an absurd third
leap of logic and the fact that she can
just say that is very troubling that
she's comfortable just flat out saying
you didn't agree with me or at least my
perception of you is that you didn't
agree with me therefore you support the
worst stuff that ever happens to me
that is the most absurd All or Nothing
kind of stance
any slightest
step that could be perceived as being
even vaguely hinting in the direction of
not agreeing with her she will paint
with the biggest villain brush she has
now some folks have proposed that
perhaps Graham or Norton should consider
suing her considering that uh the law is
about libel in uh the UK are quite
different from the US and the U.S is a
presumption of innocence yeah not in the
UK it's basically a lot easier to win a
libel case I don't think that's
something that's going to happen
partially because of her opening that
whole statement with quote unquote
bearded men rather than naming them in
specific might put it just just shy of
libel it's certainly clear who she's
implying but like it would be messy and
quite frankly she can outspend both of
them ten to one in court so
I don't think that is something that is
going to happen but that is kind of the
degree that this was that there were
people seriously asking like should she
be taken to libel Court over this
because she is not naming them in her
tweet but directly implying that they
did something that they flatly did not
do and it's a horrendous thing that she
is implying that they did so this has
been severe enough to get some people to
legitimately question whether legal act
I mean civil action let's be clear not
Criminal action but whether civil legal
action should be taken against her again
I don't see that happening now the very
last part of this quote tweet she says
you may mock but takes real bravery to
come out as an Old Testament Prophet
which
I I have to be honest I'm not a hundred
percent sure what she's on about with
that I think she's implying them as
um trying to uh take some sort of
designated male leadership role as if
this was the Old Testament I don't know
it's it it's an odd sentiment to end on
and it's at least for my purposes far
from the most important thing in that
tweet but you know completeness now
rolling and brag kind of went back and
forth basically talking past each other
with brag trying to pull things back
like that's not what I said I said this
and her going after him anyway and I'm
not gonna go blow for blow on that
because I I don't feel it's there's much
more to be gained other than what I've
already said about the matter so we're
gonna move on from that but from there
as one might expect
Rowling's supporters or at least those
who claim to be and uh you know seem to
use uh her anger as an excuse to Target
people they went after or brag and not
quite hard to the port that to the point
that Norton has left Twitter completely
and frankly I don't blame him cause in
his answer he literally brought up the
fact that like suddenly you're dragging
me into this conversation and I
shouldn't be here and then basically
what he was worried about happening that
he expressed in that answer is exactly
what happened what I feel weird about
this is what I'm asked about is then I
become part of this because I'm
wondering but the reason that this
represents a severe escalation is again
because rolling is going for the
harshest possible attack against these
men that can be had when the original
context did not involve her at least not
in his answer the interviewer tried to
bring her up and Norton dodged it Bragg
did bring her up but again if you
actually watch his answer
um and while Bragg Associated rolling
with uh Norton's reply and his answer to
that question
Rowling's response was to lump them both
together and say that they want to
redefine what a woman is and are okay
with death threats like that
that is such an immediate and extreme
interpretation and escalation of what it
was that happened that it needs to be
made very clear right now this is no
longer a matter of JK Rowling simply
stating her opinions or even being
defensive against people attacking her
she's now on the attack she is going
after actively anybody who has any
statement that even vaguely can be seen
to relate to her or her opinions and she
is going at them very hard and as a
result so are her supporters and those
who share her views this is not
defending her position this is actively
attacking others who really at least in
the case of Norton were trying to not
involve her now all this stuff with
Norton and brag that went down on
October 13th on the 15th and I'm not
saying this was in response to what went
down with Norton because it was probably
written some time ago but this is just
the timeline I'm dealing with on the
15th Rowling had an op-ed piece
published in the times and there brought
some new things to the table that again
I think everybody should find troubling
the name of the op-ed was sturgeon is
deaf to women's concerns over gender ID
which uh
all right I should probably give some uh
some context real quick as to who
Nicholas sturgeon is I'll try and keep
this short because this is just context
Nicholas sturgeon is Scotland's first
Minister and also the leader of the
Scottish national party or SNP she's the
first woman to hold either of those
positions I'm going to just speculate a
tiny bit and say there's a good chance
Rowling has probably never liked her
because part of the snp's agenda is to
have Scottish independence and have it
no longer be part of the UK which is
something that uh Rowling has actively
campaigned against in the past but
basically Rowling is painting the SNP as
being pro-trans which in her mind makes
them
anti-woman now the S P's actual track
record on trans issues is a little mixed
there was an issue at the start of 2021
when a trans member of the Party named
Teddy hope left the SNP and called it
quote unquote one of the hubs of
transphobia that actually LED numerous
lgbtqia plus active S2 to disassociate
or leave the party now later on that
same year in 2021 sturgeon and the SNP
did do a pretty sizable push and
commitment to the idea of simplifying
getting official gender markers changed
for Trans people basically giving them
fewer Hoops to jump through when it
comes to changing things on your ID
birth certificate Etc now the segment
I'm pulling from this op-ed is is a bit
lengthy so I need you to stick with me
here the third argument sturgeon uses is
that it's transphobic to suggest any man
would fraudulently claim a female
identity this claim is extraordinary now
I do want to pause and kind of address
this first what she's attempting to do
here is to completely pull apart the
idea that people say when you focus on
the idea that trans women are actually
men looking to molest people that is
transphobic now her wording is a little
bit different and it's a little bit
different on purpose she's presenting it
as what you're saying is transphobic to
suggest that that's even a possibility
and that is absurd because it's a
concern that's the way she's choosing to
approach it but the thing is it is
transphobic it is transphobic if that is
your core Point anytime trans issues get
brought up if that is your go-to concern
if that is the only thing that you are
choosing to talk about whenever issues
of trans rights or um their ability to
just live their lives if that is the
primary thing that you bring up yes yes
it is transphobic in the same way that
it was racist for Donald Trump when
talking about Mexican immigrants to say
they're bringing drugs they're bringing
crime they're rapists and some I assume
are good people him adding and some of
them I assume are good people doesn't
make it not racist because that was his
go-to point that was what he started
with that's what he hit the hardest and
so what he said was racist when you come
first and foremost for the idea that
trans women could be men looking to
molest people that when it is your first
and biggest and hardest point that is
you saying this thing that statistically
happens in a
minor fraction of a percentage of
instances of trans people so far as the
data currently shows when you focus on
that at best you are saying that we
should condemn this entire cluster of
people because of the actions of an
incredibly small number of individuals
and yes that is transphobic to take any
group of any notable size and to deny
them or attempt to restrict their
ability to get anything that will
accommodate their existence try and deny
them their human rights because of the
actions of a very small number of people
yes you are transphobic because you are
campaign meaning to lump all of them
every trans person in with the
incredibly small number of individuals
who have ever been found to do anything
close to what you are claiming and to
lump them all together and say we're
going to treat all of them with less
dignity less Humanity deny them the
rights that they are trying to get
because of this tiny amount of people
yes yes absolutely you are transphobic
because you have demonstrated how little
the rights livelihoods and Humanity of
trans people means to you rolling
continues nobody but the very naive can
fail to be aware that predatory men are
capable of going to Great Lengths to
gain easy access to victims and have
often sought out professions or special
status that offer camouflage for their
activities sex offenders have
historically been found among social
workers teachers priests doctors
babysitters School caretakers
celebrities and charity fundraisers yet
no matter how often the Scandal break
the lesson appears to never be learned
now we'll get to what she says the
lesson is in just a second but this
again is really not okay because her
immediate point of talking is to talk
about people who lie to get into a
position of power in order to in order
to do something terrible and just have
access to victims and yes it does happen
in all those cases but you know what I
don't see you campaigning to restrict
the rights or or presume the guilt of
teachers priests celebrities caretakers
social workers or doctors you're only
doing it about trans people so it's
clearly not about well this is something
that uh someone could claim or a
position they could put themselves into
that they could they could then abuse
that power theoretically yeah possibly
also all the other positions you listed
but you're not going on about them
you're not concerned about sex offenders
in any of those you are only coming for
Trans people and trans women in specific
and again this is hammering first and
foremost on the idea of whenever she
talks about trans people she talks about
sex pests she talks about sexual and
violent predators that is always how she
frames it whenever she talks about trans
people if that isn't the literal first
thing she says it is going to get
brought up eventually and then there's
what she claims the lesson we aren't
learning is and that is it is dangerous
to assert that any category of people
deserves a blanket presumption of
innocence
now
let's be careful but also clear and our
dissection of this statement first is
there is a presumption of innocence
legally there has to be now a
presumption of innocence in the legal
system is not the same as a presumption
of innocence in the court of public
opinion those are different things while
the courts do have to operate on the
basis of innocent until proven guilty
that is not that does not mean that
everyone has to behave that way in their
own personal opinions much how in
America freedom of speech guarantees
that the government cannot come in and
tell you that you can't say something
but that doesn't mean that other people
can't call you out or that private
companies can't remove your ability to
broadcast that to a large number of
people it only has to do with the
government's position everyone else gets
to handle it their own way now just to
be certain I did double check to make
sure that the UK operates on the basis
of innocent until proven guilty because
as I said like their libel laws are a
little wonky compared to what I'm used
to in the U.S in the U.S is a
presumption of innocence yeah not in the
UK but I did confirm that there is a
presumption of innocence for all
countries who are members of the Council
of Europe and to be clear the Council of
Europe is different from the European
Union the UK left the European Union not
the Council of Europe and the uh the
presumption of innocence is core to all
members of that body so the UK does have
a presumption of innocence this is again
her escalating to the most attack-based
form of position from things that she
has said in the past because what she
seems to be saying here is that when
trans women are accused of something or
even the suggestion is made that they
could possibly do something that is a
bad thing and we all agree it's a bad
thing it's presumed that well no they
can't be because they're part of this
group and that group is Presumed
Innocent the thing is I don't think
anybody actually operates on that basis
some people are quicker to assume guilt
than others and those who are
sympathetic towards a group that a
someone accused of anything happens to
be part of yes they are more likely to
go wait do we have evidence that doesn't
mean that they believe that no evidence
will ever prove their guilt which seems
to be how hard she is pushing this I
think that's what she's trying to do at
least it really does feel like she is
trying to say that you are all just
presuming that no trans woman could ever
do this and first of all no that's not
the position of politicians or any trans
activists that I personally am aware of
and when I say activists I mean active
political Advocates I don't mean random
far out there Wing nuts that you could
find online who are saying nonsense like
that I'm talking about people actually
engaged in the political process of
fighting for these rights not people
just sounding off on random websites and
none of the people taking any of this
seriously have said or even implied that
never ever would that ever happen what
they are saying is is that the human
rights and the humanity of all the trans
people in this country
matters enough
that it needs to take priority over the
incredibly slim possibility that this
thing could happen and again to be clear
if and when such things do happen like
what she's implying it is horrible but I
have never ever seen a trans person who
was accused of doing that kind of
horrificness being defended by people
who say it couldn't be because she's
trans while people are pushing back on
you about JK is the idea that you leap
to that that is what they are pushing
back at but now you are painting it as
well you just always assume they're
innocent you assume they're not capable
nobody is assuming that and she should
understand the difference between the
assumptions being made and the most
extreme versions of that because she
complains about that in the one tiny bit
of backtracking she does later in the
article because later on she says this
shouldn't need saying but in the current
climate it does literally no feminists
I've ever met claims all trans women are
Predators any more than we believe all
trans men are predators very funny to me
that she says that when literally no
trans activists that I have ever met has
said that it is impossible for someone
to take advantage of the rights granted
to trans people I don't know anyone who
has ever said it's impossible I've I've
seen and heard and known people who who
cite how incredibly statistically
unlikely it is given the current data
that we have but that is not the same as
saying that they are always innocent 100
of time like you're saying you literally
complain about the exact thing that you
are doing now the last thing that I want
to talk about is a tweet that Rowling
did
um actually I think before most of this
went down so timeline wise this was the
first thing but this is the note that I
want to end on because it is
re-emphasizing stuff that I've talked
about before in terms of the issue of
artists and the art now I've done
General videos in the past about why you
should not separate the artist from the
art and in that case I made a number of
points some of them just broadly
philosophical in that it's actually a
degradation of the art to pretend that a
human being didn't create this but here
I really want to narrow down on JK
Rowling specifically in the fact that
and I am going to say fact you can not
separate her views on trans people from
her products and her branding and
everything with her name even vaguely
attached to it and she actually kind of
makes my point for me she took an image
capture of somebody asking her how do
you sleep at night knowing you've lost a
whole audience from buying your books
her response was I read my royalty
checks and find the pain goes away
pretty quickly
at best
this is her basically saying I'm rich so
I win
but I don't think that's what she's
doing here and I don't think whether she
intended to or not that it begins and
ends there
she is basically codifying something
that she has been leaning into for a
while
which is the idea
that every sale of anything that she
gets royalties from
she is taking as support
because when someone asks how do you
sleep at night for all the people that
you've lost
she references a royalty check
and I don't think she's just referencing
the money in the sense that while I made
money so I win I think she is pointing
to that
to go these checks are so high
because people still support me and I
didn't lose that many
this is important to understand because
when we have separate the artists from
the art conversations there is Nuance to
be had there are people with their
overall opinions I'm of the opinion that
you can't separate the artist from the
art just fundamentally but I've heard
some fairly decent Arguments for people
making the case that there are reasons
to do so particularly when it comes to
something where something about the
artist is unsavory and having it
diminish the value of the art in the
first place and the sort of devaluing of
Art and pretending that it never had
meaning because the person who made it
wasn't a good person and that I agree is
not a good thing so there are cases in
Nuance to be made there is no Nuance
with JK Rowling however and I'm going to
reiterate some points that I've already
made as to why the first is this is not
a thing that she did this is a thing
that she is actively doing
continuously you could depending on the
specific effects my own level of comfort
with this is not high but there is an
argument to be made in some cases of
look that person did something that was
bad but it was a thing that was done and
unless you demonstrate like a pattern of
repeated Behavior like this was
something they kept doing or are still
doing that maybe you can at least choose
to still engage with the art on the
basis of you know they did that thing
once and that makes me uncomfortable but
I still like their art
the transphobia and the active
campaigning and now going on very harsh
attacks is something that Rowling didn't
do but is doing so when you support her
financially and we'll talk about the
implications of supporting our financial
in a moment but when you support her
financially you are enabling her ability
to continue to cause active harm and
when someone is doing active damage to a
community
that is a different conversation than
whether or not you should read HP
Lovecraft because the dude was really
racist because Lovecraft is dead and
while that doesn't make his racist ideas
some of which did very much leak into
his works completely harmless it does
mean that supporting him financially
doesn't result in him continuing to be
racism dude's dead so the issue of what
else might he do if he is continue to be
supported is not part of that
conversation
but what Rowling continues to do has to
be at the heart of the conversation
because when you support her when you
support anything financially or through
signal boosting or through praising her
work and I don't like going to that
extreme I don't like saying you can't
even say it's good like at this point
she is taking literally everything that
is not actively pushing back against her
as support especially if you have spent
any money whatsoever on anything that
gets back to her in the form of a
residual check and I know some people go
on she's a billionaire it doesn't matter
if I give her a little more money it
does matter because she takes every
single cent of that money as proof of
support of proof that people are if not
actively supporting and believe the same
thing she does at the very least it's
proof that what she's saying doesn't
bother them enough to stop supporting
her because that's the thing I know that
there are people out there who are not
actively transphobic who still enjoy or
wish to support or partake in Harry
Potter related stuff especially this is
going to be relevant because we've got
the Hogwarts game coming out and it's
going to come up as a conversation Point
again and maybe I'll have to say it
again when we get closer to the release
of that but I am going to say it again
right now
you cannot
financially support JK Rowling
and pretend that that has no impact on
the trans community
I'm not saying that you can't support
her you have the right to do with your
money as you see fit as does she
regrettably given what she's choosing to
push that money influence towards but
she has that right as do you
what you don't get to do however is
pretend that your support is harmless
because you yourself are not personally
espousing transphobic beliefs that you
don't get to do and if you choose to buy
that game or go to the next Fantastic
Beasts movie or buy a new edition of
Harry Potter or buy official merch from
channels that are going to get her
residual checks then you need to come to
terms with the fact that you are
actively enabling and contributing to
her ability to do harm to trans people
so regardless of whether you yourself
hold transphobic beliefs in your heart
you are enabling someone who does
and that is a fact
and so that is why when it comes to
separating the artists from the art with
JK Rowling specifically it is not a
philosophical issue it is an issue of
active damage currently being done
so
I am going to say flatly if you
contribute funds or in the case of
influencers publicity
towards her and her works
you are supporting her transphobia does
that make you personally transphobic I'm
not necessarily going to go that far
because a lot of people choose to bury
their hands on this and their heads in
the sand and pretend that there isn't an
actual harmful outcome for their actions
but there is and that is what I need you
to all grapple with if you still decide
to support her works that is your right
to do so but you are empowering her to
do damage and you need to come to terms
with that and acknowledge it and be
prepared to be called out on it because
that is what you have done
and you cannot Shield yourself behind
well I do believe in trans rights I do
believe in this you gave her support and
she is wielding that support against
trans people this is not up for debate
you do have the right to spend your
money as you want
if you want these things if you want to
support these things if you want to play
this game you can do that but you can't
do that and claim that you have done
absolutely no damage or claim that well
it's this little tiny bit of money it
doesn't matter every single bit of that
money she takes as support it empowers
her in her belief of her own
righteousness and it gives her the
motivation to now go on the attack as
she has been doing because that's the
other thing that I really want to put an
emphasis on there are more than a few
people out there who still say and many
of them in bad faith but some people I
think in some form of good faith who
will say
she's defending herself they'll bring up
the death threats they'll bring up the
harassment Center away which again not
okay but that is part of the reason why
I needed to talk about this because
she's not playing defense she's not
defending herself from attackers or at
least she's not only doing that anymore
she is actively on the assault against
anyone who even vaguely shows any
support that is in contradiction to her
transphobic views this is not her
defending herself or anybody this is her
actively attacking because at this point
she has adopted the perspective or at
least is behaving as though she has
adopted the perspective that the
existence of trans women is an inherent
threat to women
and that position is transphobic is
dangerous is harmful and is the kind of
position that goes down the rabbit hole
that eventually leads to the idea that
trans people should not exist at all
because they are unsafe to have around
she has not said that she has not
directly implied that as yet but that is
the end point of the path she is
currently walking a path that started
with I have concerns that went to I'm
being attacked for my concerns that has
now gone to I'm actively attacking
anyone who does not share my exact
position on this there is a path she is
on that I hope she does not keep walking
but I have no reason to believe that
she's going to stop or pause in this
progression I don't know what her exact
thoughts are I can't read her mind but
she is behaving in a way consistent with
the idea that the very existence and
presence of trans women is a threat and
that
is the kind of thought process that
leads to true
violence against people and I'm not
accusing her of directly inciting
violence I am telling you the path that
she is on and where that path eventually
goes and maybe if we are
far luckier than the state of the world
would imply we are she will not walk
further down that path but that is where
that path ends understand what you
support
when you buy her products understand
that she
takes your money as support no matter
what you think that money is
she takes it as direct support even if
you think well I'm supporting the actors
in the movie The developers of the games
you're supporting her she has said and
made it very clear
she takes those residual checks as proof
of her own righteousness and she sleeps
at night because of them
I really want this to be the last time I
talk about her I have a very sinking
feeling it won't be
but I want it to be I kind of need it to
be
it won't be
but hopefully it will be for a while
because the reason I have not talked
about her as much
is because
she was doing the same stuff over and
over as I said at the beginning though
this is an escalation this needed
addressing this needed to be a point for
me to reiterate how much active damage
he's doing I hope I don't have to do
this again for a long time because it is
draining
it is exhausting
it is deeply disheartening to find out
what people with power and influence who
have no actual standing in terms of the
nature of being Trans in terms of trans
care in terms of medical and
psychological experts who actually know
what they're talking about she has no
basis to have a voice in this
conversation as loud as the one she has
except for her influence and money and
to see how she is wielding that is
draining
but it still has to be talked about
that's why we're here
thank you for your time
if you want to support
this channel patreon is the best way to
do so
but there are other things I do as well
I'm on other platforms such as twitch
and I have books for sale there's any
number of things you can do if you want
to support what I do and
my voice
even like share subscribe those help
there is the comment section
no personal attacks not against me
Norton brag or even rolling
if I see vicious name calling if I see
implications that violence would be okay
against anybody who has been brought up
including JK Rowling I will not only
delete your comment I will block you
from being able to comment in the future
so if you can adhere to that
then drop something down in the comments
and we'll talk about it I don't want to
have to shut off comments I never have
so don't push me on this
but
I really need you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid and you are loved
you are the council I just run the
meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
[Music]
all right time to thank my highest
supporting patrons Robin Moore Zubin
fulla Tarak the theme that goes doink in
the anime Oliver B Melinda Walters
emudelki Leo the Boyd toy lowly Becky
Sparks for nobelax the poodle Zach
Bookworm Tracy scrabot angry casperal
Adam RDL Taylor Shayla Gourley Brendan
morose and TT thank you for your support
if you want to hear me try and say your
name while this little guy tries to chew
on my earrings well you can check out
the patreon or the support tears that
get you a shout out thanks so much you
are a pain in my butt
[Music]